ainsi donc l'avenir de la région
passerait par la chlorophylle c'est en
tout cas le souhait du conseil régional
qui fait de son plan vert l' axe
prioritaire du futur aménagement de
villes de france
le gros morceau 6 puis dire de ce plan
vert c'est la ceinture verte un projet
de grande couronne de verdure aux
environs de paris pour empêcher une
urbanisation anarchique mais bien
évidemment ce projet en partie réalisés
se heurte à bien des intérêts financiers
et immobiliers javier grimaud patrick
division ces engins sont en train de
construire une île sur un plan d'eau de
9 hectares comme quoi grands travaux ne
rime pas toujours avec béton le parc
départemental de la plage bleue dans le
val de marne est un des pivots de la
ceinture verte
la première tranche ouvrira en juillet
40 hectares aménagés 3 millions de
mètres cubes de terre déplacés cela
coûte cher
situé dans la ceinture verte le projet a
reçu le soutien financier de l'agencé
régionale des espaces verts cette
fameuse ceinture verte est en fait un
projet situé entre 10 et 30 km de paris
objectif préserver dans cette zone un
axe imum des espaces naturels ou des
espaces verts aménagés
rien à voir avec une lubie bucolique
c'est toute l'organisation de l'île de
france qui est en cause
constituer une barrière végétale à
l'urbanisation en tache d'huile de la
région parisienne une priorité du
conseil régional
aujourd'hui nous avons encore des
agglomérations qui ont moins de 1 mètre
carré des espaces verts par habitant
et quand on voit que dans certaines de
ces exonérations on songe encore à
construire
au lieu d'y faire des espaces r je vous
dis mais on n'a rien compris c'est ça si
vous voulez qu'il ne faut pas refaire ce
ne sont pas les erreurs du passé
pas facile pourtant de convaincre tous
les élus locaux les espaces verts
améliore le cadre de vie mais ne
rapporte rien financièrement exemple le
parc départemental de chantereine dans
les hauts-de-seine un million de
visiteurs par an mais des millions de
francs d'investissements et 14 francs du
mètre carré à l'entretien malgré les
subventions la prospérité des communes
dicte souvent d'autres priorités
logement ou zones d'activités avec taxe
professionnelle à la clé en région
parisienne
l'espace est convoité la ceinture verte
pourrait en faire les frais
rist est bien c'est que dans 20 ans ou
30 ans les responsables se trouveront
face à une agglomération déséquilibré et
dans laquelle il faudra réintroduire à
des prix tout à fait considérable de la
verdure
mais dans les conditions les plus
difficiles possible non plus modifié
dans certains secteurs la ceinture verte
c'est tout à fait évident mais il est
fondamental d'en respecter l'esprit si
l'on veut que dans 20 ans on ne nous
disent pas mais qu'avez-vous fait notre
région préservation des terres agricoles
des forêts aménagements de parcs coulée
verte
la moitié des 120 mille hectares prévus
pour la ceinture verte a déjà été
réalisées l'autre moitié s'annonce plus
difficile les grands parcs ont été
réalisés sur d'anciennes carrières des
secteurs souvent non constructible pour
boucler la ceinture il faudra acquérir
des espaces nettement plus convoités
seul moyen pour sauver l'entreprise
qu'elles soient reconnues prioritaires
dans le prochain schéma d'aménagement
régional